[Musique]
l'objectif c'est qu'un jeune pendant les
jeux
c'est à présent c'est le sport qui a
donné un sens à saige le parcours de
mathieu léonard pourrait inspirer un
scénario de film qui pourrait
s'intituler le point tournant
c'est d'ailleurs le titre de son
prochain livre où il relate une jeunesse
chaotique avec une issue à peine
croyable une preuve que le scénario du
décrochage délinquance et drogue ne
finit pas toujours mal dépressif mathieu
a pensé plusieurs fois que la vie ne
valait pas la peine d'être vécue il ya
encore quelques années son quotidien et
est parsemé de vol et de vente de
stupéfiants
courtisé par les gangs de rue seront
jamais très loin sur son chemin c'est
une bonne chose que je vois des îles
formant aujourd'hui bénéfice n'en sorte
qu est ce que je peux comprendre les
réelles d'initiation quand je parle aux
gens c'est la rencontre avec le sport
qui va le sauver
mathieu le décrocheur va reprendre petit
à petit sa vie en main avec la ferme
intention de devenir quelqu'un
il vient d'ailleurs d'entrée à
l'université la boxe ça l'était monde et
l'équipe moisi grâce au sport je
pourrais m'en sortir et harvey un jour
je c'est faux mais plus positivement que
je n'ai d'ailleurs que je suis
énormément est vraiment content j'ai du
fun je m'amuse et je vais au droit
justement l'année prochaine après mon et
préparatoire on voit qu est-ce qui va
embêter j'ai dit que je voulais
comprendre le droit que plus les doigts
pour aider ceux qui en avait peut-être
besoin aussi et surtout on ne
mentionnait pas correctement de
profilage fait tellement de gens qui
sont pas au courant de leurs droits en
tant que tel moi je vais te voir un
émerger tout grand déçu des les autres
signaux et justement c'est pour ce qui
maintenant
qu'est ce que je fais aujourd'hui je me
présente ici à montréal ma connaissance
c'est bon j'ai dit après 9,5 et des
élections cette année à montréal le 5
novembre
écoutez je vous laisse jamais des
questionnements vous pouvez me trouver
sur internet
le prochain combat de mathieu léonard
c'est avec la politique municipale qu'il
va le mener un affrontement qu'il dit à
sa portée c'est mon prochain aux régimes
à carhaix de boxe amateur que j'ai adoré
j'ai eu tellement tellement plaisir
maintenant j'ai mis ça de côté
on en sait dans le ring politique de la
boxe un peu comme justin était justin
l'a fait tout le monde peut-être moins
raide au début peu gentil gars des
mosquées son combat et le gorille sont d
un combat politique en tout le monde en
2007 il l'a gagné donc à l'ouest et des
financements très très motivant pour moi
aussi moi je présente mais seulement
quand vous montrez trajet mariage comme
bien d'autres il est la preuve que les
méandres de la rue ne se termine pas
toujours dans une impasse
quel que soit le résultat des élections
il veut continuer à être ce témoin qui
partage le message qu un meilleur avenir
est toujours possible des jeunes charge
mois de l'utiliser pour ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas pour qu'un jour le nom du
jeune qui remet sur à son grand père
sont heureux
ici robert frosi radio canada montréal